bonjour à toutes et à tous les invités
de 5 à 10 ce matin jean jarno porte
parole de l'association culture égalité
bonjour bonjour bonjour à tout le monde
merci de nous recevoir
bien sûr que les femmes doivent être
moins déjà pays parce qu'elles sont plus
faibles
elles sont plus petites moins
intelligentes cette phrase n'est pas
passée inaperçue elle a été prononcée
par le député européen polonais
d'extrême-droite janus corvec lors d'une
séance plénière du parlement européen
votre réaction ben je crois qu'il ya une
député espagnol qui lui a dit les choses
et qu'il a ramassé comme on peut dire
dans notre dans un langage courant bien
entendu c'est un machisme qui de ce sont
des propos qui ne doivent plus exister
donc ce monsieur
et comme dit l'espagnol il faut les
sortir des assemblées et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut que les femmes se mobilisent
dès maintenant et qu'on regarde bien
pour qui nous nous qui nous élisons dans
nos assemblées dans les assemblées et
que ça soit en martinique et que ça soit
dans l'assemblée nationale française et
aux eaux et aussi à l'assemblée
européenne il faut sortir les membres de
l'assemblée qui sifflent les bancs du
gouvernement femmes qui portent des
robes
ben il faut les sortir parce que ce
n'est pas pensable que dans ce 21e
siècle au début de semaine une siècle
qu'il y ait encore des gens qui ont des
comportements de ce genre si du sexisme
de bas étage ces deux comportements
rétrogrades et c'est aussi ne pas
accepter les femmes comme elles sont et
pouvoir continuer à dire que le pouvoir
c'est le pouvoir des hommes
donc il faut les sortir il faut élire
des gens qui sont des buts les gens avec
des idées féministes et qui sont des
gens avec des idées de progrès que ce
que vous pensez de la campagne
présidentielle qui bat son plein en ce
moment à bien la campagne présidentielle
est ce qu'elle est là il faut simplement
regarder des programmes des jours il
faut revoir que nous avons des candidats
nous parlons pouvons parler de monsieur
fillon et de madame le pen qui sont des
dangers publics pour les droits des
femmes à pourvoir
abba simplement quand on d'ailleurs
monsieur monsieur fillon vous dire que
on ne devrait même pas parler de lui
parce que c'est quand même c -b sans
qu'il soit encore là
s'il faut en parler il faut pas oublier
que monsieur sion a été quand même de
chef de gouvernement sous chirac et sur
sarkozy qui la met des milliers de
personnes dans la rue parce qu'avec la
réforme de la retraite qui a été une
réforme scélérate pour les plus démunis
particulièrement mais pour tout le monde
et il a été sorti
et là maintenant il revient et qu'est ce
qu'il nous dit en ce qui concerne la
question des droits des femmes
il nous dit je ne vais pas toucher à
tout ce qui concerne les droits scioli
vg mais nous dit en même temps je ne
vais pas financer des centres de santé
ça veut dire que toutes les personnes
sur la question de la contraception et
madame le pen dit la même chose ne
pourront pas avoir accès gratuit à une
interruption volontaire de grossesse
bien entendu ces gens sont poule à la
famille men entendu monsieur fillon peut
se permettre d'avoir une grande famille
quatre enfants puisque ils leur donnent
ils les fines en fait n'a pas besoin est
ils sont financés sans avoir fait grand
chose et madame le pen et essaie aussi
financer les siens donc là encore sur la
question des droits des femmes
ce sont des gens aussi qui monsieur
fillon qu est ce qu il dit qu'il va
diminuer les soins de santé c'est à dire
que il y aura de moins en moins ce de
soins pris en charge par la sécurité
sociale mais là il revient et les
revendre sur souris mais cette
transition
c'est important pour les femmes parce
qu'elles vivent plus longtemps que les
hommes elles ont des petites retraites
et ce sont elles encore qui seront les
plus victimes de ces mesures scélérates
présentés par ces gens de droite et de
l'extrême droite
alors je suis quand je pense qu'il ya
des gens encore martinez qui vont se
réunir aujourd'hui pour mettre en place
ce comité
un comité un collectif comité de soutien
monsieur fillon qui en a qui ya des
femmes qui sont et qui participent et
qui crie haut et fort leur soutien mais
c'est dire que les femmes qui ont lutté
pendant toutes les aînés qui depuis les
années soixante dix et même avant ont
lutté pour les droits des femmes
ben si c'est quand même incroyable vous
êtes aussi qu'aucun candidat ne porte de
deux propositions sur la parité non je
n'ai pas rien j'ai pas dit que les ya
pas de yade quand même des gens qui ont
des discours pour résister sur la tue la
question des droits des femmes
on a quand même philippe poutou qu'on
n'entend pas beaucoup qui a acquis a du
mal à voir c'est qui a du mal à avoir
les 500 signatures
on a quand même d'autres candidats qui
ont des associations de femmes
monsieur monsieur mélenchon parler aussi
monsieur amour je crois qu'il ya quand
même des candidats de gauche qui sont
qu'ils ont portés eux la question
d'éducation d'un conte à monsieur macro
je pense que ce on ne peut pas lui faire
confiance je crois que monsieur macron
assez travaillé quand il était au
gouvernement de monsieur hollande pour
pour diminuer toutes les possibilités et
ses lois scélérates avec la loi travail
et tout le reste tout ce qu'il apportait
je crois que les femmes ne peuvent ou ne
peuvent pas lui faire confiance pourquoi
simplement parce que toutes ces lois qui
ne sont pas destinées seulement aux
femmes quand ils ont au lait on y vote
mais elles sont les premières victimes
parce que l on mousse de moyens elles
elles ont des salaires précaires elles
ont des petits ou des petits moyens et
donc elles sont automatiquement victimes
des lois scélérates des partis de droite
alors l'association culture égalité
existe donc depuis quatre ans vous mener
des actions en direction des femmes ou
c'est de notamment d'ateliers des
ateliers qui ne sont pas mixtes pourquoi
nous disons que il est fondamental de
s'adresser directement aux femmes et
nous avons pris ce parti d'avoir en des
femmes avec nous quand nous sommes dans
ses ateliers pour une prise de
conscience parce que uniquement des fins
nous intervenons aussi au niveau des
hommes dans des groupes non mixtes parce
que ça leur permet premièrement ça
libère la parole ça qu'on pêche les
espèces de conflit nous ce sont les
femmes c'est vous qui avez fait c'est
vous qui êtes comme ça donc on peut
travailler avec ces femmes là et les
ordonner les amener à déconstruire les
tous les stéréotypes et à leur montrer
comment nous mêmes femmes dans nos
comportements dans l'éducation que nous
donne à nos enfants notre
ferron aussi d'aider des valeurs qui
sont des valeurs qui renforce les
inégalités et en direction des hommes
nous avons eu cette expérience à queue
avec le parc naturel régional de la
martinique dans un groupe d'insertion
c'était c'était de très comique parce
que il ya une homme qui nous dit a donc
nous sommes programmés donc nous
programmer pour nous y est con ça alors
on lui dit absolument que nous sommes
ses hommes c'est une culture machiste
c'est une culture sexistes et ils sont
porteurs de cette culture alors y'en a
qui me diane d'une lecture maxima
machiste et inégalités oui mais quand
même délivré par des femmes délivré par
la société pas par les femmes seulement
pas se sont pas des femmes seulement qui
éduque monsieur livory cvo médias qui
éduque quand vous ne dites pas tous et
toutes
c'est une façon de dire que les femmes
n'existe pas par les clips par les
vidéos par les publicités par les
discours que vous tenez et par tout ce
qui existe donc il est informé en valais
la femme a aussi une part de
responsabilité
il n'y a pas que les femmes qui ont une
part de responsabilité les femmes sont
dans une culture qui est une culture de
l'illégalité une culture sexistes et
donc pourquoi j'accepte de me trémousser
dans un clip
je suis une femme je suis quand même
conscience et j'ai une conscience de ce
que je véhicule comme on en voit
toujours cette histoire de détective
fallait simplement si j'accepte de me
taire ya aussi ceux qui acceptent de
passer ça c'est ça qui est encore plus
grave
elle peut accepter parce qu'elle a
besoin de travailler qu'elle a besoin de
manger de se trémousser dans un dans un
clip
mais ce qui est encore plus grave c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas de 2,2 qu'il n'y ait
pas de censure sur ses clips là qui
n'est pas de censure sur ces vidéos et
c'est ça qui est grave et donc c'est
pour ça que nous disons qu'il faut que
les médias un aussi et toute cette
société puisse avoir des politiques vers
l'égalité hommes femmes
alors l'onu dit pour 2030 il faut
l'égalité 50 50
ça c'est le knock dès maintenant on a du
travail à faire et au niveau de toutes
les collectivités au niveau des écoles
de l'éducation et c'est pour ça que
culture égalité fait ce travail
d'atelier en direction des gens des
personnes et des cadres pour que les
politiques soient menées aussi par des
gens j'en ai pris conscience en même
temps
expression par exemple l'expression
rentrée pour d'autres causes
quand manager c'est pas une expression
que l'on entend souvent dans la bouche
des hommes mais beaucoup de la bouche
des phares dans la bouche désormais la
bouche les femmes de tout le monde c'est
une expression et tous les tous les
proverbes de la marlière et des
proverbes créoles sont il faut bien tout
ça absolument absolument qu'il faut les
bannir et il faut surtout prendre
conscience dans ce que nous transférons
quand nous le disons et le langage
forêts pourtant féminiser le langage sa
voix qu'il y a des et des choses quand
on dit par exemple un petit garçon nommé
du plan comme une petite fille ça veut
dire qu'un garçon qu'est ce qu'il doit
être il doit être un homme viril forêt
tout qui n'a pas le droit de pleurer qui
n'a pas le droit d'avoir de sentiments
et ça aussi notre langage est très
important dans la construction d'une
société d'égalité homme femme
est-ce qu'il faut déconstruire jeudi
entre parenthèses le mythe de la femme
potomitan aussi à nay le déco soit gros
coups de marteau à bon compte pourtant
nous sommes pas des femmes potomitan on
nous a aussi ça renforce les gens c'est
bien tout le monde dit nous sommes des
femmes potomitan on applaudit non nous
sommes des femmes et on veut partager
les poteaux là vous voyez avec les
hommes
donc on ou non leur place et je crois
que personne plus personne de dix ans
quand la femme potomitan nous nous
sommes des citoyennes et que nous
voulons être des citoyens à part entière
cette société et surtout partager les
tâches ménagères et ça aussi ça aussi on
en parle parce qu'on dit les tâches
ménagères c'est pas grand chose mais
c'est ça le basique des inégalités entre
les femmes et 10 hommes pour le 8 mars
vous avez plusieurs manifestations dont
un jeu de piste avec donc des enfants à
fort de france l'objectif alors déjà
comment ça va se passer pour nous c'est
notre manifestation phare et on félicite
sylvie javaloyès emmanuel la nuit là
célestin qui ont pris ça à bras le corps
et d'ailleurs c'est une ça a été pris
salle quand je veux dire le logo de le
sexisme c'est pas mon jean par le
ministère des le secrétariat des droits
des femmes
donc qu'est ce que c'est avec la fcpe
l'association des parents d'élèves la
fcpe et les enfants qui sont en centre
aéré le mercredi matin 65 enfants sur la
savane de fort de france
nous allons le remettre des questions
caché dans toute la savane ils vont
courir dans toutes la savane pour des
questions sur quoi
la question des femmes sur la question
d'égalité hommes-femmes jeu la question
des métiers tout ce qui concerne les
stéréotypes les préjugés que nous avons
et c'est très important parce que il
faut absolument que les enfants soit
sensibilisé très tôt à ses affaires et
surtout que les personnes qui les
encadrent c'est pour ça que nous avons
proposé une formation à la fcpe pour les
animatrices et les animateurs donc on
donne rendez vous aux gens pour regarder
ses enfants qui vont courir dans tous
les sens et on va leur donner un grand
diplôme de l'égalité hommes femmes
alors ça c'est le 8 mars le 11 mars vous
avez une manifestation également revenir
mais dans nos éditions d'hier deux
journaux mais vous avez également édité
il laisse très peu de minutes livre
intitulé rebelles et marronne ben oui ce
livre est rebelle les marronniers
jusseaume elle a toute sa place ici
c'est pour montrer justement aux femmes
qu'il y a des depuis la colonisation les
luttes contre les cales colonisation
avec un ak una healy à des femmes qui se
sont battus et qui se sont levés contre
la colonisation contre l' esclavage
contre les justice contre le racisme est
donc que nous disons qu'il faut que ces
femmes là continuez nous disons que le 8
mars c'est chaque jour chaque jour c'est
le 8 mars et nous avons nous invitons
rapidement aussi des gens à venir faire
la fête avec nous mercredi soir au
garage populaire pourquoi vous ne faites
pas ce sera ma dernière question
nouvelles pistes rapides pourquoi vous
ne faites pas des actions communes avec
l'union des femmes de la martinique vous
êtes fâché si elle nous invite on y va à
l'année dernière joue pas par hasard on
a été vite en est allé à cette réunion
de préparation n'y a pas eu de fuite
roger fâche il nous sommes fâchés avec
personne une féministe ne peut pas être
fâché avec notre mouvement d'aidé qui
défend les droits des femmes pas du tout
ni les mouvements progrès dans leurs
lois et rory nom n'a pas fois nous
n'avoir une somme a failli personnel
reçoit toutes nos invitations n'y a pas
de chance à georges arnaud vous remercie
sa en qualité ni bonne journée à tous et
bonne journée et puis bon il mars et
surtout que tout le monde marque
quelque chose se passe quelque chose
merci à nos attentes